all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
where I in the morning give my thoughts
on life coffee
you know whatever whatever we're gonna
we're gonna
speak on all right before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today
today I'm gonna be speaking about
Twitter as usual right I know a lot of
people are saying why go back and forth
with people on Twitter
recently it's been taking up a lot of my
free time it's become some would say a
hobby
and I actually don't mind Twitter
because
it really is almost like a
uh
a whole I don't want to say a whole uh a
peephole see this sounds weird but in
opening like a way that you gosh a way
that you can see how Society thinks
because
I can put something that's really not
controversial something I think is basic
and it's really interesting to see how
people respond
um
so today what did I tweet about
there's this lady named
um and I think I've tweeted back and
forth with her before about something
I can't remember but
I was talking about how traditional
relationships work better than this like
50 50 partnership now
that's not to say that women can just
not work which I've gone over before
historically women worked we just worked
in the house
all right guys if you wanted to see I'm
telling you I grew up with some of these
Amish people
I mean I grew up but like we got
furniture from them so I kind of saw how
they lived
if you guys think that like working in
the house back then was just like this
soft life you are sadly mistaken oh my
gosh I actually I want to do a video
where I go to the Amish and like live
like them for a week I think it'd be
really interesting
oh yeah this girl named Brianna Wu and
it's interesting I got some Instagram
stuff from people telling me some
insights about
but you know I don't know what's true
it's not true but
it doesn't even matter
she basically saying I've been married
15 years therefore I am the authority on
marriage over me
and I think on the surface that makes
sense right
I mean come on she's got more experience
than me
if she wasn't arguing with me over basic
things now a lot of criticism I get is
that I give advice and I don't really
think that the tenant of my channel is
advice although you know I'm sure it's
in there from time to time
the tenets of my channel is really more
of a curiosity for truth and
really making observations about Society
in the world and what we've seen is that
50 50 Partnerships don't work and I
think it's very clear in the data and
the results and what the Liberals will
say though the women have always been
miserable they always wanted to leave
but they couldn't under patriarchy
and I think anyone with half an brain
slash IQ can see that is just not the
truth so
what do I talk about in marriage I say
women submit to your husbands
women don't get fat women have sex with
your husbands is this crazy marriage
advice
is this
off the chain you need a PhD in marriage
I mean call me crazy I don't know call
me crazy
but I got to thinking why is this so
controversial why are married women
arguing with me
and I realized we have a whole
generation of people that have never
seen happy traditional relationships and
we're all just trying to figure it out
but my generation has seen you guys's
generation right my the 20 year olds
have seen the 30 and 40 year olds and
said whatever the hell they're doing we
don't want to do that because this is
horrible I mean the married people we do
know as a group
get divorced or the white or like
they're all miserable they hate each
other they're arguing like how many
happy
35 Plus couples do you know in our
generation it's not many
and so we see what you guys did and we
also see the married people
we see the married people where the wife
is just run in the relationship and we
say you know that doesn't look like it
works we don't really want to do that
and the old people the oldies will come
to us and say well you're not married
you're indebted into your personal
attack personal attack personal attack
and we're like look
you guys have fun over there do that but
our generation we've seen we've seen
what you guys have been up to and we're
not with this well I don't want to say a
lot of my generations to lose but
the the enlightened thinkers
so that's why I say and this is what I
tweeted this I said
a lot of you offer marriage advice when
you obviously wear the pants in your
relationships with your husbands no good
I'm good lady I don't care how long
you've been married if we gotta argue
about submission
like it shouldn't be that crazy this
shouldn't be insane advice this used to
just be the norm it was like water is
wet sky is blue but now we live in a
society that we've been so brainwashed
that women need to be in the Forefront
of everything that now we're saying that
the sky isn't blue and anyone who says
the sky isn't blue is call me crazy
and my question to the Liberals what
evidence you have that this 50 50
partnership type works
I need some evidence
because the conservatives will say hey
we can point to the marriage rates then
and the marriage rates now
and the Liberals won't like that but
their their counter evidence is no
evidence
next all right
um
I you guys are so
crazy
they really don't like my style
dang so this guy I met this dude and he
took a pic with me
all right and this is the picture we
took together
dang for the love of God get pearl of
stylist how how y'all got her looking
like this homely at a convention
and now they're photoshopping different
hair stylists on me is it that bad guys
you know what's funny everyone comes at
me I am much better than I was a year
ago I'll tell you that
you guys might say oh Pearl her style is
so bad whatever you know and in the
coffee thoughts this doesn't count this
is just my morning thoughts
and I'll say this it is much better than
a year let me find you guys
I'm gonna find this I'm gonna find this
I really lived in sweats like the fact
that people say to me now I've never
seen you without a dress on
crazy to me because my whole life I
never wore dresses I was a tomboy guys
but let me know maybe I want to find
this thing they photoshopped on me
maybe you guys
and then they'll also pull like kind of
the most unflattering angles of me
it's like a bit rude
foreign
I can't find it they photoshopped me
okay oh now oh this girl just responded
to me let me see my Hundred my husband
is a hundred percent my equal this is a
man that cannot be tamed I would do
anything to support him and he would do
anything to support me he is secure
enough in his masculinity to not need a
weak partner to feel like a man
does this look like a
sorry I'm not gonna do that I'm sorry
all right
I mean I'm just I'm not trying to be
rude because then they're gonna clip it
and say see
Pearl goes after family okay I'm not I'm
gonna try to do that but
we'll look at the pictures and we'll be
like well this doesn't really look like
a masculine man that you're speaking
about
you know
um
this one they tweeted the picture at me
okay
um and if we make any observations it's
like rude and
anyways this is the whole thing our
generation is looking at you guys
generation you guys's generation did
marriage so bad that our generation is
afraid of marriage that's how bad you
guys did marriage so before your
generation is gonna
um your generation did so bad that even
the married couples like the the kids
that come from Married families are
afraid to get married and have kids
because they don't want to live a life
like you guys's generation
so as much as you guys want to come at
our generation and say oh you guys have
no life experience like because they'll
do that to me to sneak like some of the
younger people talking about this stuff
um well we've seen the life experience
that you guys have and to be honest it's
not great it's not great
now I'm not saying I got all the answers
but I'll tell you I'd rather
I'd rather go die alone than do what you
guys did
because what you guys did honestly has
ruined marriage for everybody
call me crazy
um
God I wanted to say something but I
won't I won't
now I've also seen I guess there's a
girl make
this is on me I don't really know
um like I've heard of her I don't even
watch them to be honest because they're
all just personal attacks
and I think she
yeah a bit a bit a bit naughty a lot of
times these crazy ladies just get
obsessed with me to the point they're
photoshopping different outfits on me I
kind of I think it's kind of funny it's
like
why are you so obsessed with me you know
call me crazy I don't know
but it's really interesting how
a 26 year old can have such an impact on
full-grown adults
like I got these people fuman
like I tweeted
I got this one guy on Twitter that's
always insulting me and calling me ugly
and
um
single and it's like do you guys think
if I had a boyfriend I'd be sharing it
with you with the with what you've done
to my boyfriend my ex-boyfriend that you
know about do you think I'd be sharing
that call me crazy I don't know but
you know let me
let me know what you guys think in the
comments really you guys's generation
ruin marriage for us well we're we're
out here looking at Solutions we're
making observations about Society about
what works
what doesn't work and all we get back is
personal attacks
but anyways guys you know like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell I'll talk to
you next time